[Música]
vamos a hablar del hambre en américa
latina y el caribe que está en su punto
más alto desde el año 2000 tras un
aumento del 30 por ciento en el número
de quienes la padecen esto según un
informe de la onu al menos
59.7 millones de personas padecen
insuficiencia alimentaria
la prevalencia del hambre en américa
latina y el caribe se sitúa actualmente
en el 9.1 por ciento la tasa más alta en
los últimos 15 años aunque ligeramente
por debajo del promedio mundial de 9.9
por ciento lo que se traduce en que 4 de
cada 10 personas en la región es decir
unos 267 millones experimentaron
inseguridad alimentaria moderada o grave
esto en el año pasado 2020 60 millones
más que en el año 2019 para ello quiero
saludar entonces a lola castro y
directora del programa mundial de
alimentos para américa latina y el
caribe lola gracias por su tiempo por
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 porque estamos viendo este
aumento y porque cada vez más entonces
personas siguen diciendo de hambre
buenos días sí como lo han dicho bien en
267 millones de personas están
padeciendo inseguridad alimentaria
severa en nuestra región y realmente no
debería ser así porque la instalación
produce alimentos suficientes como para
alimentar a toda la población porque
estamos viendo esto primero porque ha
habido un descenso de la capacidad de
las personas de adquirir comida es decir
no ajax no tiene una capacidad de
comprar la cesta básica y eso ha pasado
como bien has comentado en los últimos
seis años ha empezado a deteriorarse y
luego cuando tenemos una pandemia del
cobi que realmente afecta a las
poblaciones que no pueden tener empleos
que no pueden vender sus productos que
los sistemas ministerio se ven afectados
vemos un deterioro aún mayor y todo esto
claro sería posible resolverlo pero en
este momento las cifras que vemos
realmente no son muy positivas y vemos
como no vamos a alcanzar los objetivos
sostenibles desde el 2030 como nos
habíamos marcado el alambre cero en
nuestra ocasión y en todo el mundo lola
como atacar el hambre cómo podemos
resolver este problema
mira en nuestra región tenemos varios
como hemos mencionado el acceso que la
gente no puede comprar sus alimentos
otros tenemos un gran problema de
malnutrición y el plan además decisiones
tanto de personas desnutridas es decir
que están muy delgadas que no pueden
adquirir que no pueden y no han comido
adecuadamente las vitaminas
micronutrientes que necesitan para tener
una vida sana pero también tenemos
muchas personas obesas y esa obesidad es
enorme es uno de cada cuatro personas
está obesa en nuestra región y tenemos
que reducir en sus rápidamente una dieta
saludable tenemos la suerte en que la
dieta saludable pues está a casi cuatro
dólares por persona en esta versión está
más elevada de todas las realidades del
mundo entonces cómo resolver todo esto
bueno no tenemos soluciones primero que
los sistemas alimentarios funcionen un
poquito mejor y que realmente haya
acceso a las personas una dieta
saludable con un costo más reducido y en
este sentido tenemos que apoyar también
a los pequeños granjeros a los granjeros
que tienen una capacidad de producir
diverso fresco y con bajo costo segundo
podemos también cómo se hizo durante el
convite extraordinariamente nuestra
oración dar transferencias sociales a
las personas más pobres y vulnerables en
nuestra región conseguimos un récord de
326 millones de personas recibieron
transferencias sociales durante la
pandemia si eso se pudiera sostener o al
menos mantener para los más pobres sería
un gran apoyo para que estas personas
puedan comprar una fiesta y una dieta
básica luego hay ejercicios muy
interesantes como es la alimentación
escolar si los niños en la actual las
reciben una dieta saludable se van a
mantener sanos en la en la infancia y
luego van a ser adultos sanos y
productivos es decir hay muchas
soluciones muchas más que tenemos en
nuestras manos en nuestras acciones y
realmente las debemos implementar tanto
con gobiernos como con naciones unidas
estamos trabajando en cerca
con mi ser con la gente y con otras
agencias más para realmente que esto se
ha traducido en realidad lola hablemos
ahora también de un fenómeno que está
afectando ya también la producción de
los alimentos y estamos hablando del
cambio climático con la sequías extremas
que estamos viendo también inundaciones
como esto también afecta la seguridad
alimentaria sobre toda nuestra región de
américa latina y el caribe
pero nuestra región de américa latina y
el caribe y especialmente el caribe las
cosas que deben estar altamente
afectadas tanto por los huracanes como
por las sequías como por las
inundaciones hemos visto por ejemplo en
el 2020 vimos huracanes que afectaron a
millones de personas y toda la costa
caribeña y realmente el mayor problema
de esto es que necesitamos estar
preparados tener información y también
al tener esta información a ayudar a las
comunidades a que se adapten comenzará
una comunidad al cambio climático porque
prácticamente a veces cambiando los
cultivos que usan en vez de hacer tan
por maíz hacer otros productos como
pueden ser la yuca la cazaba que están
son más resistentes tanto a la sequía
como a las inundaciones
entonces si conseguimos realmente
cambiar adaptar a las poblaciones en esa
en esa área también realmente apoyarnos
a respetar a proteger sus cuencas
hidráulicas tanto para que tengan agua
sana y saludable sino también para qué
cuando llegan las inundaciones no caigan
las erupciones no caiga toda toda la
tierra y realmente se creen esos grandes
eventos de la
caída de montañas y desaparecían de
comunidades de izquierda que estamos
viendo nuestra región tenemos lugares
como haití que también son de gran
preocupación ya que tienen grandes
problemas de también terremotos
inseguridad alimentaria y todo esto
junto tenemos la necesita bajar ahora
para el futuro la adaptación en el tema
de benito importante y tiene que suceder
en este momento tenemos un minuto lola
para la última pregunta y le quiero
preguntar entonces por el panorama que
podemos esperar en los 122 se puede
mejorar si es esta situación o
lamentablemente va empeorar
bueno el panorama como lo estamos viendo
ahora es de un gran aumento de los
precios de los productos alimentarios
también estamos viendo un aumento del
transporte de los productos alimentarios
y realmente tenemos que hacer un fácil
en asegurarnos que pasamos por el
vulnerable tienen ingresos o tienen
transferencias sociales para evitar que
haya un aumento mayor de esta
inseguridad alimentaria severa y
moderada que tenemos en la red